>> Bret: WELCOME BACK TO
"SPECIAL REPORT."
TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE THINGS
STAND IN UKRAINE TONIGHT.
THIS IS A MAP OF RUSSIAN
OCCUPIED TERRITORIES, CONTROLLED
AREAS AS OF YESTERDAY INTO
TODAY.
THE KEY POINT HERE IS THAT IT IS
AROUND THE CITIES.
NOT IN THE CITIES.
AND YOU CAN SEE THIS.
THERE'S A CITY DOWN HERE
MARIUPOL BASICALLY ALL OF THESE
CITIES ARE SURROUNDED IN ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER BY RUSSIAN FORCES,
KHARKIV IS GETTING BOMBARDED.
BY SHELLING.
BY MISSILES.
NOT GUIDED MISSILES.
IT HAS CHANGED.
THE PENTAGON OFFICIALS AND U.S.
INTELLIGENCE IT HAS GONE INTO
THIS SIEGE MODE FOR THE RUSSIANS
AND UNFORTUNATELY LOOKS A LITTLE
BIT LIKE GROZ ANY, SOME BOMBING
IN KYIV AS WELL AS SHELLING IN
MARIUPOL, A NUMBER OF
ENGAGEMENTS ON THE GROUND BUT IT
IS NOT COMPLETE CONTROL OF THESE
BIG CITIES WHICH IS A TESTAMENT
TO THE UKRAINIAN DEFENSE FORCES.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT
THIS RUSSIAN CONVOY, 40 MILES
LONG.
IT IS STALLED, ACCORDING TO U.S.
INTELLIGENCE.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOKAT HERE THIS R
WHERE DOWNTOWN IS RIGHT ABOUT
THERE.
THIS IS THAT CONVOY GOING ALL
THE WAY UP PAST KYIV GOING ALL
THE WAY UP.
THEY HAVE SUPPLY ISSUES.
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY STALLED.
IT'S A LONG CONVOY OF ARMORED
VEHICLES, TANKS, THEY ARE GOING
SUPPLIES WE ARE TOLD AND THERE
IS KIND OF A RESUPPLY EFFORT AND
THEY ARE REORGANIZING BUT RIGHT
NOW IT'S ESSENTIALLY ON HOLD AND
THAT IS A GOOD THING FOR THE
UKRAINIANS, EACH DAY THAT THAT
HAPPENS IS A GOOD DAY.
IN THE SAME MOMENT KYIV HERE 660
TO 680,000 REFUGEES GETTING OUT
OF UKRAINE TOWARDS POLAND AND
THAT IS CLOGGING THAT ROUTE.
AND AT THE SAME TIME YOU ARE
GETTING SOME COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY TO FIGHT ALONGSIDE THE
UKRAINIAN FORCES.
THAT IS A NEW PHENOMENA AND THEY
ARE DOING SO WITH WEAPONS FROM
COUNTRIES AROUND THE GLOBE.
THESE ARE ALL THE COUNTRIES
SENDING WEAPONS TO UKRAINE IN
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
THE U.S. AMONG THEM, THE BIGGEST
WEAPON OF CHOICE IS THE JAVELIN
ANTI-ARMAMENT TANK MISSILE
THAT'S BEING USE SOD EFFECTIVELY
BY UKRAINIAN DEFENSE FORCES.
BUT THE QUESTION IS CAN THEY GET
IT FAST ENOUGH?
CAN THEY HOLD THE RUSSIANS OFF
BEFORE THEY GET INTO THE CITY OF
KY